okay so this is the suitor this is an
episode where peppermint Butler's doing
god knows what they say I said don't
with peppermint yeah it's just like
dude he's like taking part in the dark
arts he's got cinnamon bun like hanging
upside down playing some sort of dark
demon in him and he's got all these
weird things lying around but then one
of the giant one of those statues
crumpled garden gumball guardian's comes
and not gonna distract me this time well
done Joey so you know comes and says hey
there's all these suitors waiting to to
talk with people's you know or to be
with their year is supposed to be in
charge of this so he finds this one at
the end a line actually like the son of
one who died and because many have been
waiting there like 300 years and stuff
and so finally he says okay you're good
it sends him in there his name is Braco
and they're doing this because peoples
is too into her science she's gone like
days and days without sleep and so he
comes in she's still not interested but
he just vows I have to live up to what
my father said I have to fall in love
with you and I do love you and blah blah
blah so she figures had a guinea pig so
kind of use the same as a guinea pig for
a bit and he loves it and finally he
wants to do something nice for her so he
takes this quest away from her asks for
this quest I guess from Finn and Jake to
get this sort of was it like a soul or
cool stone soul stone he goes get that
gets horribly burned and you know this
figured and stuff brings it back turns
out people doesn't need it there's a
better one or she makes a better one
so I goes back to peppermint Butler who
use this absurd dark magic to make
anyone who sees and fall in love with
him but also it disfigures the hell out
of it like even more so Oh
the peppermint Butler really is in love
with him I guess you know I have my
babies yeah and so yeah just sort of
goes and back to people's and says
please let me be with you and she's like
no I can't but here's a robot me you
know and goes you know he seems to like
that goes off with her tells peppermint
Butler what happened then he slaps are
really hard it's it's my favorite
animation because it just looks so
painful ideas like your glasses fly up
in the air flying it's so detailed where
there's Joe and it it just makes this
like it's so much painful so you should
have given him to me so yeah I thought
this was uh I thought it was a fun I
it's nice seeing um I get there is a
part of me that can kind of identify
with the workaholic aspect I I think in
that moment where she's like you know
like her eyes are like all regal so just
like you know I wanna do this will do
business like I can I've had nights
morning's like that so uh yeah and I
guess the big thing too sir goes in my
head is whether or not you know I'm
watching this something in myself
okay he's committing himself to her but
anything doesn't know anything about her
you know I media I'm sure he's like yeah
but now those suitors do you know they
just want cuz that water cuz that's just
how things go with how they're Sooners
there's royalty we must exchange land or
whatever so shall we exchange led yes
so so yeah so he said like it seems like
he's very committed to convince himself
that listen love you know so it's not
something Riesling necessarily doing it
for anything bad or evil it's just this
is kind of all he know what's cutsies
the only one you know they got in it is
bother what you know Dottie to give him
this post so just the guilties feel from
bad I'm sure uh so yeah and I think it's
like you know it's the only thing he's
gonna understand is a yes and so he
gives this Robo her you know that's just
gonna you know obviously just say yes
you know and goes
often yeah sort of all he was looking
for really was just a doll I'm he's just
looking for something and he's looking
for a prize here's your prize you know I
buy but I like that they don't make him
like me nor a jerk or anything like that
idiot yeah well he's just lost and it's
just an nobody you can see why because
he wasn't race or they his father was
dumb enough to wait in line for however
long and then somehow it's like where is
his wife it did the why did he somehow
give birth I mean it's like we don't
know but but there we are that's the
situation um so I think the only thing
we were talking with jury a little bit
about this like with people's really me
than this are what she nodded I think
the only thing I can't go home about is
her using him as a guinea pig which is
really funny I mean don't get me wrong
but at the same time I'm like it is kind
of leading him on a bit unless you could
argue that the whole thing she was
working on that whole time was just
making a robot for him that's possible
you know cuz he he's like she's like
constantly measuring this stuff and
she's measuring when he's in love and
Cassidy I think that's what was going on
the more thing about it yeah she was
probably cuz anytime he's like trying to
he's wearing the Hat and trying to sort
of come on to her you know he's after
she's at soon with something and that's
almost at the readings and stuff I mean
it yeah that might you feel what's going
on so that would make actually total
logical sense so yeah I'm fine started
to see my daughter off-camera going in
your face mom no III don't think
people's was being a jerk in this one I
love you sweetheart but no people's was
being Peebles that's the thing he's been
in line for 20 years
yeah he's an idiot for doing this 20
years of being around someone seeing how
they act you should learn to grasp on to
how they are well the way bubble you
gradually see her he's just waiting
outside but they are coming and going
I'll tell you the fact that she can do
my thing she just walks in a walk
that's it but the fact that she
consistently ignores them that one guy
for 300 plus years that should kind of
say something right there
well yeah true but okay but this guy is
born into this lied all he knows this
this lie it doesn't matter the whole yes
it does that's all he knows he doesn't
know anything from Rachel go ahead you
know husband's father sounds like you
know the minute other womb it's like all
there is is this line and give it oh my
god that's all very offensive bubblegum
yeah well yeah I don't think people's
was leading him on I don't think I was
the key was foolish because yeah he was
boy it was blind love like when he runs
up to Finn and Jake and it's like here
I'll do that I want to do this or he was
following them and they're like yep I'm
go ahead and Finn go s-- you know Emmett
remember it was like this is a lost road
like like Finn tells him
you're being if you're being an idiot
for this you're not gonna get anywhere
with this and he does it anyways and
like I can't feel bad for him getting
beaten up or maimed or whatever they
because he's being an idiot well he's
not an adventurer he doesn't know what
he's doing
Finn and Jake does that's what they were
given the job and he was not well but I
mean I feel bad for the guy because like
I said he doesn't know any better he's
going to and his his intention is good
he just doesn't know that it's foolish
and idiotic uh I will say this that I
think this used to I see this coming up
more and more in stuff where it's like
because the mindset before I think at
least I know when I was growing up there
so we sorted this mindset of if I try
hard enough you know if I love you
enough like you'll love me and we'll be
happy and was meant to because I love
you so much you know that sort of
mindset and I think that probably came
from like a lot of programming growing
up or movies or shows busy you know
steam movies and the shows yeah and
there's sort of this thing now where
it's like they build it up you know
that's like no it takes to you know it's
two people they both have to agree but
they both have to agree you know to come
together it can't just be one person I
really love you
if the other person doesn't it bats in
it there's no like hey I just have to
love you more I have to do even more
it's like no then you're just going
after a prize you're not going after a
relationship you know so I think the
sort of thing I'm seeing this more and
more now where they're trying to make
that more clear may because there have
been so many years of you know just
looking at a person as a prize you know
sort of thing or if I if I love you
enough that'll win the day yeah so I
like I like movies I like shows that
very clearly show that this is not how
this works it's you need both parties
you need two people because I think
they're probably I'm sure there still
are now you know people that are very
nice kind people they just don't know
any better they're they're not very good
the stuff in a very smart but I mean
there's there's people that do this
stuff and they fall into these traps of
thinking you know serve this very naive
quote-unquote innocent way of if I just
love more or it's something I'm not
doing I'm not doing and should know it's
you know it's you need the other person
the princess that into you let it go so
yeah so I like that this sort of tackles
that even though I know it's not the
first probably won't be the last but I
still think it's a good it's a good
thing to keep emphasizing I'd like some
clarification from the people in the
comment section in her office in
people's little office I saw milkshakes
and I know that's not the cat's name
from a Gunter's child was there oh I
can't
the pink cat with the bandages around
and I saw the bandages but was that I
think it was drawn a little differently
I think that's supposed to be that's why
I'm asking if because I know they
checked some of them check the wiki and
all that stuff yeah that ant if you look
behind Peebles into one of the cages
looks like the guy from Thief City
excuse me where the one that my jammies
Mike
it looks like that's him in the cage
back there literally you did seem like
for like I totally miss I did a little
bit of time so I'm just curious if
anyone else caught that or if that's
supposed to be him or not I won't know
you can Jet Set it's like just go away
nerds go find this puppy I know that's
what your free was in you're like I know
I can look it up myself this I got my
Mountain Dew not worth it and mountain
dew baja blast limited time only he is
the only person mark says a mountain
tear the bends I person more upset
minute yeah I see it
thank you and what is the story behind
that it's the one from Taco Bell right
talk about have their own special
mountain dew and are they - now they
have to and they can the one it takes to
make a thing go right it okay there you
go
it takes to couple it takes to do yeah
and also while with peppermint Butler
again like I said don't mess with
peppermint but I was always wondering
you were talking about when you said
that now it's like don't you evil one if
you also look with peppermint Butler
there is the ghost demon thing it from
remember the dungeon where Finn jumps
down and he tries to test his skills and
then he's just alone with the cat that's
like who kind of knows everything do you
remember that cat not especially but you
know I used to love him too um basically
that Ghost is there as well that Ghost
deems that the really white one that was
the other than okay yeah it's this show
it's so tough because it's like there's
always stuff it's like I swear I
remember that I know I saw sober but
it's like God what what was it again
hope for a long ago I mean like you were
saying there's a wiki of it I mean of
course there is yeah that's like that
must be insane because there's just like
a million things that keep coming back
and have a backstory and stuff that yeah
it must just be crazy and by the way I'm
not telling to go do it for ya you are
it promotes conversation no no you're
just awful
possibly now there's no possibly it's a
definite he put me on the same level as
peppermint Butler uh no he's at least
cute but I'm evil
oh yeah drinking Mountain Dew
shut up